[Music]
[Applause]
a member of the 2021 basketball hall of
fame class former nba on tnt analyst
course fab five in michigan chris webber
joining us uh congrats there chris uh on
the hall of fame did you play football
in high school
you know i did i um i played tight end
and uh you know once we got the red zone
i was pretty good but
uh i was really good i thought but i
don't know what my quarterback would say
because i really couldn't block that
well so um had a lot of fun though
playing football that's my favorite
sport when i was growing up did you
think did you get recruited to play in
college
you know it's funny i i did a little bit
um but funny story i met uh bo
schenbecker um and uh he used to bring
me into the locker room before the games
nice to see the guys getting pumped up
and one day one of the guys looked at me
at my legs and he was like oh yeah oh
yeah twigs or something
i just remember being like nah i'm good
and just seeing those guys that were my
height but if i would have had you know
role models like uh
gonzalez or any of these tight ends that
play basketball i definitely would have
tried a little bit more besides in the
street tackle on the side you know alan
iverson talks about he could have played
he was a better football player than a
basketball player can you see that
he's really serious about it i mean he's
almost it's almost like a regret with
him that he didn't get to play football
but i've seen him and jason williams uh
throw a football
um with other football players and that
type of thing and i can only imagine a.i
with how he moved mike looked up to ai
so that would be you know pretty cool
but um you know you were just if i could
change the subject one second you're
just talking about usc
um i don't know about you know slovis i
don't know about his game but his father
was my point guard in high school and so
i know his father was was pretty tough
and he was a heck of a basketball player
so i wonder if slovis has it in his
jeans but me
yeah i would love to have been a
football player man best moment of the
hall of fame weekend was what
my father put my jacket on me
uh
you know that was just special i really
enjoyed it because my family were
outgoing bunch i had a bunch of brothers
and sisters and so
uh
everybody was like move out the way this
is my weekend and that's that's kind of
how families are and i needed that and
so uh it was their enjoyment that my
father put in uh
why was isaiah thomas so important to
you growing up
well you know we didn't have social
media you know tv stars you couldn't get
to home he was the best player one of
the best players in the world he was
best friends with magic
uh
you know just trying to go through the
uh celtics turn the ball up you know
just a big pistons fan you know and uh
the fact that
you know i'm in high school it's all
this noise around and you're young
you're vulnerable you don't have anyone
to talk to and you know your dumb kid
you know the fact that he
called our house sought us out
uh gave me advice and was there the
whole time uh it was just awesome and
what i mean by there the whole time you
know when you're younger a lot of times
you just need something to hold on to
and i have the fact that i have this
number and i can call it any time well i
had the fact that you know when guys are
getting in trouble or people are getting
you know i had a friend you know
passed away in the streets and isaiah he
went through the same thing and so
you know i just want to thank like
mentally he just didn't even know and
it's more for that 16 17 18 year old kid
you know 20 year old kid i just really
thank him because at that time it was
like
i know somebody that did it i know
someone that did it i got to hold on to
the values you know what i mean it
really kept me separate from from some
knuckleheads and things that could have
happened so
just awesome having him uh awesome
having him on my mind did isaiah recruit
you to indiana
uh no isaiah never recruited me to
isaiah never recruited me
did magic recruit you to michigan state
hold on a second my kids are at home
school be quiet down here
daddy's working
how many kids are at home
uh two i have uh twins and uh
four-year-olds and uh
you know they're about that life so i
gotta wake up early and be ready for
life
[Laughter]
waited for this long to happen but
anyway um no he didn't he didn't recruit
me
to indiana it's funny uh the point guard
that i mentioned earlier and max he uh
took me to indiana with him and i got to
meet like uh
it's funny it was an unofficial
recruiting trip but bob and i had to
know because i go to practice with my
point guard from high school and
lawrence fonda burke is in there and
he's going like this don't come here
and lawrence went to ohio state
transferred yeah
oh that is funny so you're seeing
lawrence thunderbird who's on the
indiana team and he's saying do not come
here
okay then i'll be quick um
so i go into that locker room and then
during practice it was crazy because
they had like eight managers and the
managers were taking stats and practice
i had never seen anything like this and
i was a big big 10 fan so i wanted to
meet bobby knight couldn't believe he
could look me in my eye and he was tall
and big and on a red sweater and
everything and so i get the chance to go
in the locker room while all of them are
huddled up calvin cheney i'll never
forget this and i had a hat on
and like the guys were like you better
take that hat off uh bobby knight's
gonna come in and smack you in the head
like they're scaring me teasing me you
know i don't know what's going on but i
figure out that they're joking and then
i'm like man it's nice man i love the
way the arena the seats go all the way
up to the top it's cool here it's cool
and uh thunderberg is just doing like
this like no coach comes in and he just
he stops and the next year he transfers
so uh
you know he saved me from even thinking
about indiana
did did magic recruit you to michigan
state
yes
oh boy and you had to tell magic no
you know
as much as i love isaiah i love magic
because imagine was from the state and
so
when i was 12 years old i go on this
interview and uh
they said what school do you want to go
to i never thought about i said michigan
state because of magic and uh the next
day i get a call from judd heathcote uh
this is when time is on i actually
became close during this time and i get
to go up there and as a 12 as a 13 year
old with my green school corduroys and
white shirt i get to run a game with
magic johnson um at the jennison field
house i'll never for i'll never forget
it it was he and kevin willis and a
bunch of other players and i missed the
pass and
hated myself and caught one and made a
layup i had penny loafers on i mean
it's the weirdest story but yeah from
there he would talk to me and try to
recruit me and you know all that good
stuff so yeah i was a big fan of
michigan state growing up talking to
chris weber member of the basketball
hall of fame class did you want to uh
do what michael jordan did and maybe you
know jab some people make it a roast
when you're up there
nah
no i didn't that's just not
no i didn't i didn't i i did watch a
bunch of speeches and
i saw you know michael jordan's i saw a
couple others and uh but no after i saw
like shacks and someone else i forgot
who i was but it was so funny and that i
was just like just be yourself don't try
to entertain don't try to do anything
and lay some eggs just you know
hopefully uh you know be honest and get
the hell up out of there
so where do we stand with michigan here
what's going on
you know i
i don't you know i'm i'm good with
michigan i'm going to the game in a
couple weeks
so
you know i i don't i don't know um i'm
not you know
in the space to go back and forth with
anything i said the ward apologized to
me he did he said that
and and maybe it was the way that it
came with the crawl or something so i i
i expect him to
validate what i'm saying to you right
now
so go to a hotel room and
we meet this is about five years ago i
don't know how many years ago it's a few
years ago um
uh we go to a game swiss passing a week
we go meet with each other
and it was very nice there's four people
in the room
um
and uh
you know we have copious notes of this
time so everything that i'm saying is
100
and he just says you know
we like to apologize to the
18 to the 20 year old chris webber we
did not protect him we understood what
was going on we've done our research it
is not what was reported and we're sorry
and i said a bunch of things to that
that was
uh not contentious at anything because
he didn't owe me that or it wasn't an
official statement or anything but he
knew
and he knows
and that's that's all that it was that's
why i didn't say anything about it then
and just happened to say something about
it now
i mean dennis
i'm helping you know i'm you know doing
all i can for juan younger players
things like that so i mean i am part of
michigan that can't be taken away and
i love the love that has come from the
school and i expect all of us to view
the game really soon
and uh have a great time so i think it's
i think it's in a great place one person
can't make it you know not being a great
place is kind of what my frame is from
my friend of mine is
you know the alumni school so i'm
i just can't wait to get back to the
game and uh just start enjoying it so i
think we're all in a great place why is
this still an issue 30 years later
damn i you know
it's it's crazy um
i kind of you know it's funny so
in michigan it's a big thing kind of to
people outside of detroit so if you're
in detroit it's never matter detroit has
been the only that's sustained of course
people everywhere but i mean detroit is
detroit and michigan and zion harvest
university just you know um but outside
of michigan it's not even a it's not
even a thing actually it's you know a
little bit you know people are like a
little bit mad
uh talk to me like why are you talking
about it forget them have fun you know
so i don't know but i love the school
then hopefully with the everything they
know i will say this hopefully what the
whole thing will allow
is there's so many new things that i've
been doing and wonderful things and
people and all that hopefully it will
allow new conversations or just a new
place to come from i don't know then i
hope it doesn't continue to be that way
because
one quick story when i went to the game
with um john harbaugh
he asked me to come back it was it was
the best film right but there was this
thing where the player goes and has
lunch with the team the media and
everything so i declined all of this and
it looked like i was a jerk but as i
explained to john i don't want these
guys to be around me and it's polarizing
like i don't want every question to be
about this and this 22 year old kid
doesn't even know what we did you know
yeah so that's the only thing i hate
about myself is that i can be used as a
polarizing figure and hopefully you know
just through the actions no one talks
about the
hundreds of scholarships at michigan or
anything else that we've done so you
know it's a wonderful place it's good
and we're gonna outlive any negativity
um so i'm just happy that you know we
can go back and uh cheer uh and have
some fun
what if johanna
what if juwan howard asked you to be on
his staff
no
has he asked you
no then his ron is so close but no he
knows i'm not i'm i'm not an assistant
coach and no disrespect to him but
that's why we can do all we can to help
each other from around point of view so
i think i can do more from him as a
colleague as someone in basketball
someone that knows the young guys uh i
could do more from outside of basketball
than in his locker room because anytime
he needs me i'll be in the locker room
that's that's just that's just
you're more of a head coach guy
i just uh i just asked i just have
aspirations on my own and uh you know
definitely has to do with the nba what
do you want to do when you grow up
um when i grow up yeah
hopefully i'll have these two uh twins
take care of me daddy's uh they're
getting tired but um no i i look forward
to uh continuing to do all the things
you're doing in business i'm really
excited about it
and um you know hopefully i will afford
the opportunity to uh
to come back to basketball
um you know in a in a in a different
position and hopefully one that you know
can impact the team in the city and
still try to win a championship you want
to be a gm
no i i want to be part of an ownership
group i want to
be part of an ownership group and help
build a winning team are you close to
being part of an ownership group
well you know i've taken two shots and
we missed both
one you know
almost did the kawhi except it bounced
off the seventh bounce but uh hopefully
you know we're gonna keep we'll keep
trying man you know i'm gonna keep
trying definitely
uh can you what do you get from the hall
of fame yeah jacket
what else exactly uh you get a ring
uh did you get um a big beautiful uh
magnum bottle of champagne um
yeah uh man
um and you get a nice gift pack and some
other things like that but uh the
coolest thing is just being able to walk
around in
the hall of fame by yourself and see
your exhibits see
everything that kind of built for you
and the narratives and everything's kind
of being done then just
you know every year just hanging out
with bill russell man like uh this year
he didn't uh cackle as much but usually
you know you've been around a million
times i'm sure and you know that loud
capitalism
you're right
yeah anyway goes in as a coach like
people don't realize being a player
coach
back in the late 60s i mean
i mean it's really incredible
to be able to could you imagine is there
somebody who could be a player coach now
i don't i don't know how without
inciting you know
i don't i don't know how because i think
the players have so much power
that if you know if you have that much
power and the coach is good it's still
kind of
you know 11 guys can negate the power of
that one superstar player and actually
you know i'm not i'm not i really don't
see how he did it um i think it was the
respect that he commanded at the time
when i talked to players like kareem or
you know spencer haywood he talks about
the fact that
uh he wasn't kind of accepted in
basketball they you know they said we
have an illegal player on the court and
it wasn't until you know kareem shook
his hand and bill russell shook his hand
put it like this they had to
allow him to wear the beard back then
they were like not too many players we
you can't wear a beard and so they allow
specially to wear here that's the power
that this man carry the fact that you
can't get facial hair or not in the nba
unless you speak to him so i just think
it was the reverence the power
that he carried
uh congrats always great to catch up
with you and uh and good luck with the
alma mater thank you chris
hey thanks so much for having me that's
uh chris webber member of the hall of
fame class and a former nba on tnt
analyst
and fab five at michigan